So I'm still getting through my stories about
the irresponsible virus disinformation that's
happening each weekend and a lot of it is
happening on Fox News.
And there's so much of it.
It's taking me through Tuesday to actually
get caught up on it.
So I want to go through a little bit of Judge
Jeanine Pirro's show from this weekend on
Fox News.
Here's Judge Jeanine asking.
I know people are dying.
I know people are sick.
But what about the rest of us?
We just have to stay home.
Another example of embracing the let them
die strategy that we talked about earlier
today, sheltered in their homes, have been
patiently watching this unfold.
I've seen the data and the facts change from
day to day.
First, there were 2.2 million who were supposed
to die in the United States, and then it was
a million.
Then it was five hundred thousand.
Then two hundred and fifty thousand.
And supposedly mitigation was already taken
into account.
Those numbers.
OK.
We have to stop.
First of all, a judge using the word suppose
a bully.
Come on.
OK.
And she's wrong.
2.2 million was the possible death toll.
If we did nothing.
And this is a game that they're playing now
to say, hey, we could have lost 2.2 million
and now we might only lose 60000.
So therefore, Trump is a hero.
2.2 million was if literally nothing was done,
which no president could actually get away
with.
It seemed like Trump was going to do nothing
at first, but obviously he he could not actually
get away with doing nothing.
It's a ridiculous bar to be saying we could
have lost 2.2 million.
Anything shorter.
Anything short of that is a victory by Donald
Trump.
Let's continue, though, and we understand
there are still many sick and dying and density
and hot spots are to be treated differently.
But what about the rest of us?
We want to go back to work, feed our families.
And as governors sit there and pontificate,
we are the ones experiencing the reality that
for every percentage drop in employment, there
are five to ten thousand deaths occurring.
Depression, suicide, domestic violence, child
abuse, resurgence of alcoholism, drug addiction,
loss of hope, battered women locked at home
with their abusers, abused children not being
identified or protected because they cannot
go to school.
I'll wear my mask, my gloves, and I'll keep
my distance and I'll do the testing whether
to determine if I have covered or whether
I have the antibody.
But don't you even think about tracing or
tracking or giving me a card?
It ain't happening.
If you're wondering if she's drunk again,
I don't know the answer.
Judge Jeanine appeared visibly impaired on
her show a few weeks ago.
It's less clear this time, but she's certainly
not making anymore sense regardless.
People are sick and dying.
But what about us?
The answer is you get to live.
Hopefully, you hopefully don't get sick or
die.
That's what we are going for here.
And Judge Jeanine continues with her rant.
And she does seem more unhinged than normal,
whether it's alcohol related or not.
I do.
I don't know, but very, very unhinged.
Your models are out of control.
The economy is out of control.
China is the one that's out of control.
We're not going to let you destroy this country
or our way of life.
We've worked too hard and we fought too long
to lose it to our war.
And that's what I said.
Our war and virus that China knew about openly
lied about said it couldn't be transmitted
from human to human and intentionally protected
Chinese citizens from the virus, but allowed
that virus to be released.
Putting the rest of the world at risk.
You want to control people, you politicians
want to flex their muscles.
We'll start working on how you're going to
punish, ostracize, alienate and financially
sanction and make China accountable for what
they did to us and the rest of the world.
Of course, the economy recovers.
Dead people don't recover.
Judge Jeanine, who was actually a judge once.
Which is crazy, is ranting in a way that's
not that different from the guy urinating
in the subway station while ranting about
the second coming of Christ or whatever.
Then we get to the cherry on top.
Judge Jeanine actually brings on a protester.
This is a protester from Michigan and praises
the protester, I guess, for putting people
at risk of infection.
Take a look.
Debbie Dingell, who is the Shah's senator,
didn't have nice things to say about you guys.
And I was rather shocked.
Here she is, a representative of your state,
criticizing this this peaceful protest.
And it was pretty peaceful, saying it was
inexcusable.
What what are Michigan's reaction to her?
Well, I can tell you, look at Michigan.
Look, it's the nation.
What we've done with Operation Gridlock and
has ignited a fire that has spread across
this entire nation.
Arizona, Pennsylvania, Texas.
I mean, today, New York, great example of
gridlock.
People rising up all across this nation.
All right.
And you know, a lot of people are very proud
of you, Michonne, and what you've done and
let me just say, Debbie Dingell is a congresswoman
and not a senator.
Of course, the issue isn't whether it was
a peaceful protest.
Again, they are just completely changing the
parameters of the discussion.
The peaceful nature of the protest isn't at
issue.
The public health risk of the protests is
what's at issue.
They called it operation gridlock.
They are gridlocking streets and preventing
patients who need care from getting to hospitals.
And this is how the echo chamber works.
We're seeing it happen in real time.
Trump tweets about liberate Michigan, liberate
Minnesota whenever Trump says protesters are
being responsible, even when they're not.
And then Judge Jeanine brings on a protester
and acts like they're doing some amazing principle
thing when all they're doing is putting people
at risk of getting the virus and compromising
the long term economic stability of the country.
Remember?
They're insisting that in the short term,
opening will be good economically.
Maybe it will.
Maybe it won't.
But what we know from the 1918 flu pandemic
is premature.
Opening is bad economically in the medium
term.
And here you see Fox News sort of pick it
up and carry water openly promoting and supporting
the protest against social distancing measures
on which we are all relying to keep us safe.
This is the situation in which we find ourselves.
It's not a bad dream.
We can't just wake up from it.
We're dealing with
this
in reality.